[Music]  this is our only chance  we have to take it  [Music]  we need calm the world needs him  to stop what's coming  and this child she's the only one he'll  communicate with  i knew that they had a bond she had  nowhere to go so  i made a promise to protect her  [Music]  and i think that in some way khan did  the same  [Music]  it's godzilla  [Music]  these are dangerous times godzilla's out  there and he's hurting people and we  don't know why  there's something provoking him that  we're not seeing here i'm at the same  opinion  the myths are real there was a war and  they're the last ones standing for  greatness because i'm built from it  nobody gonna stop for me kong bows to no  one  [Music]